j lo behind a veil holding her bouquet
and posing for the mirror the new picks
are exquisite and there's video too
giving a start to finish inside look
from artist sketches to the elaborate
beating designer ralph lauren just
released this behind-the-scenes footage
detailing the creation of j-lo's
show-stopping wedding gown over 1 000
handkerchiefs and 500 meters of fabric
were used to create the classic
turtleneck gown jlo actually wore three
different ralph lauren dresses for her
weekend i do's
i bawled throughout because it was so
damn beautiful ben's pal director kevin
smith told e.t canada what it was like
witnessing the vows was it one of the
most beautiful events i've ever been
present for overwhelmingly emotional i i
you know i'm a crier
a source tells e.t ben and jyn were
elated with their wedding weekend but a
lot of people are wondering why wasn't j
lo's bestie leah remini at the nuptials
you'll recall the couple kind of became
instagram official when leah posted this
pic from her 51st birthday party well
leo was reportedly busy getting ready to
send her daughter sophia off to college
in june she posted this sweet video
celebrating her 18th birthday
[Music]
but back to the stunning new images of
j-lo's ralph lauren gown the designers
one of her favorites from these super
casual tie-dye sweats to her western
theme met gala moment last year did you
come up with a look this evening
was it a collaborative effort
jlo also wore ralph lauren for the 2019
cfda award showing off her abs and
sharing her connection to the designer i
grew up in the bronx so of course i had
to wear ralph lauren tonight also from
the bronx i know he understands a girl's
love of crop tops ponytail sparkles and
a little drama
[Music]